you may recognize our next guest as the
culture expert
and life coach on the emmy-winning
series queer eye
please welcome from our los angeles
studio caramel
i brown oh my god this is so exciting
how are you
oh my gosh caramel i'm so excited you
know you are the very first
person that is actually walking through
our yellow doors from los angeles
i know i feel honored i feel like in a
couple years i'm gonna have like some
trivia question
and this will be one of them so i'm
honored
i have had the greatest pleasure
just doing a deep dive into you and your
life
and i've been reading your book
and reading your story about your family
um has been such a telling thing
about you as a person because
when we have sort of an unorthodox
path in our families like society says
you get married you have 2.5 children
you do this you do that you do that
um that is not everybody's exact
path and i know that
i would have loved to have been married
with my two children
and with their dad forever and things
didn't go that way but
i am so close with his family and we're
healthy and we're thriving
and when i read your journey of you and
your family
i'm so in awe of the honor and grace
and the behavior and the attitudes and
the choices that you made can you talk
to me about that because you just seem
like the best person
well i appreciate you saying that but
sometimes we get these narratives in our
minds that people tell us
of how we're supposed to be how we're
supposed to look and how our families
are supposed to
are supposed to function and the
actuality of it all is that
it doesn't have to be that way we can
define our families we can define who we
are and love
our families and love who we are just as
we want and
i didn't have a traditional family you
know my the way that i became a father
as you know from reading my book is
i found out about my son when he was 10
years old it was
the only girl i ever dated and had
sexual relations with not to get too
deep but you know we i lost my virginity
and then all of a sudden 10 years later
here's this kid
and it was the decision at that moment
to say do i step
up and try to do what's best for this
child and heal the generational wounds
or do i try to go with what society
tells me a family's supposed to look
like
i'm having a little bit of an aha moment
right now because i realize
in that moment when things you know
weren't exactly as we think they're
supposed to be in society there's a
tendency
to run away from it or to find the fault
within
and i feel like what you and i are
sort of promoting is hook in to that
family
and choose to be together choose to stay
together
um despite that it doesn't match this
perfect like societal
you know cookie cutter sort of thing and
reading about the way that you are with
your family
i was so inspired reading about that
thank you
i just want to say can we go back and
say preach drew when you said hook
in that is the mantra that everyone
needs to take away right now
hook into those moments where you feel
uncomfortable hook into those moments
where you feel like this is the moment
for me to
retreat or to build a wall instead of
fleeing
hook yourself in because when you hook
yourself in and you connect
that's where you find the strength
that's where you find the ability to do
what's right for yourself but also for
your kid
and that's what the true intention is
this hook in this connection
what is this about what are we doing
with this it's to make sure that this
little guy right here can turn into a
really super sweet happy healthy big guy
and so we got to do everything together
and so that's the mantra that we're
that might be the next book hook in you
might just give me the title
well i wonder if maybe that's what in a
way
is why maybe we are hook in type of
people is because we saw the alternative
part of this um understanding that the
challenges the challenges we had in our
families
and the things that have led us to be
these hook-in people is that you have to
understand that every time you have a
challenge it's like a slingshot
it's pulling you back it's pulling you
back and you can start feeling
weighted down by it you start feeling
down you start feeling like
why is this the family i have why is the
situation happening like this
and it's just continuing to pulling you
back and what i've learned is that each
one of those pullbacks are lessons and
when you get to that place where you can
let go
and just say you know what i got the
lessons i'm ready to hook in
i'm ready to be present you then let go
and you soar to greatness
i'm just so grateful that there is a
life coach
and someone who is there to help and
guide people
with your wisdom and perspective and
practice
so we're going to go to a quick
commercial and then when we come back
um we are going to talk about something
that even beyonce is a fan of
um and you know anything beyonce says
and does
i i want to listen
[Music]
you